do
hello everyone and happy monday welcome
back to et canada live kate is here and
you have the best highlighter on i've
ever seen we get a close-up of the
highlighter on look at her cheeks
suzanne our makeup artist i mean bang-up
job today i always get compliments when
i do this though afterwards so suzanne
really deserves the
kids you have a great face too oh wow so
there's that oh my goodness we're
starting to show up with a bang
now before we get into more uh headlines
from today cheryl's going to compliment
me some more yeah yeah
no we're actually going to circle back
to friday night where toronto's matteo
roach had her jeopardy run come to an
end my goodness
and while she went into the final
jeopardy with eight thousand dollars
difference she answered the question
incorrectly while her competitor
danielle moore uh guessed correctly and
beat out matea by one dollar one dollar
just one dollar
in a new interview matteo reflected on
her jeopardy journey and her cool cash
winnings that total over half a million
dollars amazing run for her take a look
i can't help but think back to your
first victory when you earned you know
thirty thousand dollars and you said my
student loan is gone now over 500 000
later
wow oh my god i'm like i'm trying not to
cry because like my student loan being
paid off was like the biggest possible
thing that i could have dreamed of when
i came down here and so
to have that happen in the first game
was just the most incredible feeling and
i felt like everything else after that
was just going to be basically playing
for fun
and you know play every game like it's
your last and that's what i tried to do
i really tried to fight till the end and
i can't even fathom like this amount of
money i don't know what it is in
canadian dollars but this is like it's
unbelievable can we do that math right
now what is it in canadian dollars kate
i'm i mean i wasn't ryan our director
get out your math
what is
dollar
while we move on um all right now we're
going to turn to a moment from well we
get this uh weekend that people can't
stop talking about uh drake and jack
harlow stepped out of the kentucky derby
yes
during jack's interview with nbc sports
drake hilariously
i've always had trouble with that word
hilariously interrupted and things took
quite a turn when the crew tried to wrap
up the interview take a look
yes y'all you can't give the rapid up
signal
what are you going to cut to right
what are you going to cut you're shaking
jack harlow y'all
what are you going to cut to get like a
shot of a shot of like poorly manicured
grass or something you know what i'm
gonna tell them i'm gonna tell them just
hold on we're going home all right drake
and jack harlow
churchill downs
that's it unbelievable
why am i not doing that interview why am
i not wearing the green jacket doing
that interview the guy wearing the green
jacket for that interview deserves i
don't know some sort of like live award
of some sort because he really rolled
with the punches there and i feel like
he did a great job so not only did that
clip go viral on social media but
another moment from jack harlow with the
kentucky i would like to roll with those
punches
the internet talking yeah and the
kentucky derby's official tick tock
account posted this video of jack
being carried across the muddy track
just before the main race so his wee
shoes would not get muddy can we
just you and i talked about this in
rehearsal
do
you remember
when ariana grande got a lot of trouble
for being carried because her heels were
so high and she didn't want to
like
if you've ever walked in heels you know
this hurts it's really difficult and
jack harlow does it and it's on tick
tock and it's like and people are like
great job man great job it's so
different so it's so cute i mean
i love it also like later on in the day
he's like hanging off of balconies and
stuff so i don't really even know if
this was necessary for me but it's
perfect but it just seemed to like
really
yeah encapsulate the day for them um but
back to the interview like i mean
whoever
whoever the guy in the green jacket is
was just such a delight and he seemed
honestly so happy that drake just sort
of bombed that interview
yes because drake for those of you that
don't know drake does not do press
no the last interview might have been
the one he did with me
where he said he liked my teeth i'm
joking but it's been that long
that it's been a while drake doesn't do
press he just doesn't do it so the fact
that this happened is amazing and drake
if you want to do an interview i'm just
saying i'm totally ready cheryl is ready
to put on the green jacket super ready
to that
we can make that a thing and we can pump
that out on social i also i also love
that drake was there like they were
there shooting a music video and jack is
from kentucky and i feel like drake was
speaking a lot about how proud he is and
how happy he was to join him for this
because it was sort of a shout out like
jake shout out to his
hometown very similar to the way you
know drake does a lot of stuff in
toronto and shouts out him his hometown
so i feel like it was just sort of a
great little
loved hometown shout outs yeah yeah why
not right all right now moving on to
sherry shepherd who is letting the world
know that she isn't mad at wendy
williams for not wanting to watch her
new talk show yeah now as a refresher
sherry's new show is slated to take the
time slot of the wendy williams show
following its cancellation in february
yes and during an instagram live with
fat joe on saturday wendy had this to
say about sherry's new gig
is there plans for a new show or are you
coming back to the wendy williams show
come back to the wendy williams show
absolutely
absolutely wow because i know they were
talking about
sherry sheppard
taking over the show about a new what
but i won't be watching her because i
know what she's gonna be doing and
that's really not my thing um
you know you know what i'm saying like
anyway but i love
i love being on my own show and i love
that people love to watch it
okay and later that day sherry responded
to wendy's remarks while on instagram
live as she headed to a mother's day
brunch hosted by kevin hart
did you hear about wendy's saying she
won't be watching your new show yeah i
watched i watch wendy williams her live
with fat joe absolutely did
um and i
and i did watch that she
i did hear wendy say she will not watch
me on the new show and that's okay i you
know i understand
i'm not mad at wendy is
she's going through a lot i would say
that everybody should be praying for
wendy right now i'm very concerned i'm
really
truly concerned about her
because i don't feel like there's
anybody over there protecting her and
it's really hard when there's no
protection around you and you just have
people hanging on
so um
yeah
but i'm not i'm not mad at wendy because
she won't watch my show
there sounds like an awful lot more to
that story
than we all know than what's going on
with wendy correct i think so i think
that i think um you know speaking to
some wendy fans in the office i think
that in general people think that
there's a lot more going on behind the
scenes here that wendy's not sharing
with the public which i mean rightly so
like if she's going through private life
is present it's private um i mean i i
don't think
uh you know i mean i think the other
thing is like i was asking people like
do you want to see wendy come back
because i think that's the biggest
question here is like what we knew as
the wendy williams show is no longer
that's cherry shepherd's spot now as far
as i know that that's what they're going
to continue on with and you know wendy's
dealing with a lot like you know she's
still recovering she's still working
with like you know having graves disease
which is difficult
she's still dealing with her wells fargo
um you know bank she says in that
instagram live that she only has two
dollars and she's had people
helping her out with money
you know and i think she also is
you know dealing with some stuff like
she's just dealing with some stuff so i
think you know
people bring up i find when i talk to
people about this people bring up
brittany in this conversation because
there was talk of conservative ship with
wendy williams but it's also about a
woman's agency like if wendy doesn't
want it i mean she's you know she's a
grown woman
there's always more to the story and i
think i i don't think the conversation
should be even if wendy will come back
because i think for the fans you know
fans of wendy williams want to see her
come back and because sheri is doing
so a different sort of show when you
compare those two women they're doing
completely different shows what sherry
will bring to that time slot is very
different from what wendy and i can
understand why wendy wouldn't be
watching it if it's just not her thing
it's just not her thing and sherry was
very gracious and saying that she prays
for wendy and she she hopes that someone
is looking out for her and i think
that's that's a good thing yeah what are
people saying um we do have some
comments about this um bbean says if
wendy was going to come back she would
have already come back yeah um and they
also say that uh they think that they do
think that wells fargo is stealing some
of her money so i it's just there's so
many layers to the story and it's like i
don't like you said i don't think we're
getting we don't know all the details
you can't you can't no it's really
difficult yeah but i mean for fans of
wendy i hope you
get to see more of her yeah in the
future yeah definitely yeah all right
the first official teaser trailer for
avatar two is officially here cheryl's
very excited about okay you know how
carlos and morgan get really excited
about super real jazz that is me for
this i just want everyone to know so the
film which is officially titled avatar
the way of the water look at my eyes is
the sequel to one of the highest
grossing movies ever and i don't know
why i'm doing with my hands this looks
like is um set more than a decade after
the events of the first film that's
right avatar the way the water will
follow the sully family the trouble that
follows them the lengths they go to
to keep each other safe
the battles they fight to stay alive and
the tragedies they endure
okay
we are about to watch the trailer for
the first time i'm i've never seen
avatar so i'm angry at you i'm sorry and
i feel like what do you mean
uh i'm sorry i don't know what to say
i'm ready to watch this trailer though
could you watch it tonight and then call
me later and be like no no i won't be
able to do that for you right yeah you
have a toddler right now
does that happen we do want all of you
guys to leave your actions in the
comments so that we can get to that so i
have something to say about this because
i
don't know if i will can we watch it now
is it
can you cool the monitors
[Music]
oh wow
beautiful i'm seeing beautiful shots
oh
[Music]
let's
[Music]
wherever we go
this family
[Music]
before they wrote
[Music]
okay i would just like to show you
something that i recorded today this is
me as an avatar i don't know if can we
see it here this is what i want oh you
look beautiful i was in the movie james
cameron if you need a person
the canadian one i'm your girl yeah so
there you go um i am really excited for
that i think so you seemed very excited
for the potential of them having a child
well you know how much i love babies and
i love kids and stuff so yeah but like
is that big to the storyline
well is that would that be a big deal or
is that just them moving on no one no no
this is about a love story that
transcends time
at first they were like riding some
dragons now they've gone underwater i
saw that it's a real
it's a real story about life in the real
world
versus life in this world oh gosh
look at that
and i love that it's underwater i just
think that there's so much conversation
around
the climate yeah doing all of that i
think this is a beautiful i know there
was lots of talk in the water okay so
this teaser trailer had previously been
played uh during cinemacon in april
um and now it's most recently being
debuted exclusively in theaters during
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness screenings over the weekend yes
and back at cinemacon our very own
morgan hoffman spoke with one of the
stars zoe saldana about the highly
anticipated release of the film's first
footage
people freaked out you know at cinemacon
we got to see the first footage of
avatar
i mean i'm kind of jealous that you got
to see it before i did but um that tends
to be the case it's okay i i did see 20
minutes of a very rough cut of the
ending and i was so deeply moved that i
couldn't even utter any words to to jim
um so i'm looking forward to seeing this
trailer but i'm going to take it his
advice i'm going to go see dr strange
um i'm going to hop over to my marvel
neighbors my family too
and i'm going to go see the trailer
there because i he really wants me to
sort of like
take in the whole experience of like the
imax and the sound and everything
i spotted a baby bump you did i did
is like so perceptive i all like well
maybe because i'm like
overwhelmed with always spot a pump love
a good bump love a good bump um this is
spectacular like i can't wait you know
what i'd like to watch this here in the
et canada studio
just a recliner and just right on this
tv i would like surround sound
this is going to be spectacular i can't
wait
i don't i don't doubt it at all and i
know that people are i know that people
are very excited to see this i'm with
the people
you are definitely with the people yes i
just have never seen avatar i'm excited
for you to see it because i do think
you'll really oh like it okay
but not until your toddler sleeps yeah
once i get more sleep then i'll
then she's on we'll let you know okay
great prince harry is showing off his
acting skills in a new tongue and cheek
promo video for his eco travel
non-profit organization travelist yes
and in the new camp the new campaign
video by maori uh values on mayor
television's current affairs program
harry is ambushed by ratings agent who
wants to assess the environmental impact
of his 2018 trip to new zealand with
wife meghan markle take a look
[Music]
are you in position
roger tui i have him in my sights and by
my sights i mean my eyesight
oh okay this guy's fast i'm going in
over out
oh uh hi
are you okay yeah
i haven't run in a while
you know we actually invented jogging
the australians no aotearoa new zealand
oh it's terribly sorry i know you guys
hate that kia ora kia ora just while
i've got you here
does this ring any bells
what is it it's a lolli wrapper okay you
dropped it i don't think so well
according to my report at 2 17 p.m
october 29th bethel's beach tamaki
makaro new zealand 2018.
might have been a confusing time it was
windy uh i know it was confusing it was
incredible time we had an amazing time
in new zealand it's beautiful i know
right it's a joggers paradise
oh hang on a second
it's okay it's a walkie-talkie
have you given him his rate
roger that on it now
what's this all about so you know how
people rate the places they visit oh
yeah well imagine if those destinations
rated you back
that's cool yes it is and we're trialing
it now for the first time so i'm here to
rate you on your recent visit to
aotearoa in new zealand in 2018. okay
you'll be moderately happy to know that
you scored three stars three stars out
of what 100 100 no out of five okay
really funny
i think i really kept waiting for it to
be like
oh funny er funnier funnier i love
listen i love harry i love all the
things that he's doing and things like
that but i was waiting for it to like
like really slap you were waiting for
the avatar to come out of that
no
you know what i expected it to do what
ryan reynolds commercials do
you know those are so
that production company that he has what
are they called maximum effort maximum
effort this is shadow to maximum effort
shut up we love you oh my gosh i was
waiting for that kind of funny i see i
see yes i mean i you know what i
actually i watched the whole thing and i
actually didn't people are really like
down on harry for his acting in this but
i don't think it was that bad it wasn't
his acting it was the storyline it was
they didn't you think it was just the
sketch and whole they didn't get to it
enough like i think
yeah yes i mean we've seen the guy who
plays the the ratings agent um i feel
like he i he's probably most notably
seen him from jumanji but i think he's a
new zealand comedian yes yeah super
funny um and i mean like it's a cute
idea
listen it's almost there it's just it's
almost there in the product it's almost
there it just needs to be tightened up a
little bit the writing a little tighter
that's just my opinion
but who am i but harry did a great job i
thought he was funny yeah yeah um
uh kenzie kenzie j says oh harry um but
harry should totally host snl that'd be
interesting
why not why not be super fun let's do
that
um francis is not as funny from harry um
but it wasn't harry's fault i don't
think again you don't think it's harry
potter the tv land i think it was more
yes and then um yazzie says how is harry
a better actor than some whose acting is
their actual job i mean i like i'm going
to say it again i don't think harry did
a bad job with that but i agree i feel
like maybe it could have been a little
bit
it's just tighter it's just tighter and
again maximum effort would have crushed
that okay so
new zealand yeah when you're looking to
do commercials maximum effort we have a
guy yeah we'll connect you too yeah
maximum yes that's it hi ryan
okay go ahead all right that's all
from us this monday
thank you so much for joining us and
sharing all your comments as always
we'll be right back here tomorrow on our
youtube facebook pages at 2pm eastern
yes and kate might be back with her
great highlighter but before we go
we have some good vibes for you anthony
anderson has officially graduated from
howard university yes congrats to the 51
year old who took over instagram on the
weekend to share the exciting news that
he graduated with a bachelor of fine
arts degree writing a part on instagram
to quote biggie it was all a dream words
can't begin to describe the emotional
rollercoaster i'm on right now it's
literally been 30 years in the making
this is just the beginning yes also in
attendance at the graduation ceremony
was tragedy p henson who gave a stirring
commencement speech at her alma mater
alma mater
film yep where she also received an
honorary doctorate
bye everyone
alma mater howard
i challenge you to look for the good in
yourself the joy in the world every day
how would i challenge you to look for
the good in others
to offer grace to others because you
know they are fighting a battle just
like you
howard i challenge you to take care of
yourself mentally and emotionally as
well as physically because you look too
good on the outside to not be doing the
work on the inside
thank you
how would i challenge you to keep the
little child within you alive and
thriving give them room and space to
play
i challenge you to listen to that voice
within yourself the one that's separate
from instagram twitter cable news and
the latest gossip and reality tv the
voice that just yours that's just yours
the voice that's there in your quiet
moments when no one else is around
that's your instinct
that's your discernment that's your god
voice train yourself to hear it listen
to it will you do that for me please